türen sind türen
wir mussten leute ich bin ja kein
schlechter mensch aber ohne spaß ich
kriege ich die krise
wenn ich abends in meinem zimmer sitzen
video aufnehmen möchte und mich wird von
allen seiten ich krieg von allen seiten
so direct attacken von solchen scheiß
insekten der kriege ich die krise sitzt
das auch in meiner softbox drin sonst in
die teil überhaupt fliegen naja gut
zurück zum thema herzlich willkommen
zurück zu einer weiteren folge micro
soft facts die sollte eigentlich
vorgestern kommen also am dienstag da
hatte ich allerdings keine zeit weil ich
da deutsch abitur geschrieben habe und
danach hatte ich einfach keine
motivation mehr die vita fünf stunden
eine scheiß genauso geschehen hat neuen
video aufzunehmen
ich hoffe ich das verstehen deswegen
kommt als ersatz das heute also ein
bisschen verspätet zu sehen kann auch
gestern im ort review heute erstmal hier
eine frohen ersten mal euch alle nicht
auf ihr seid alle mit fahrrad unterwegs
und guckt euch dieses video nicht an
nicht jedenfalls wurde mir ein toller
fag zugesendet und zwar ich spiele
wieder latest snapshot komplex per mail
schreibt ein konkreter gmail.com ich
garantiere nicht dafür dass ihr das
ganze hier noch nicht kennt falls es
keinen schreibt in die kommentare
ich kenne ist der konsum aber kann ich
nicht garantieren kann sein dass wir
schon als kind ganze serie basiert
darauf dass ihre sachen zu sehen
das heißt also wenn die sachen schon
neben einem anderen video vorkam
dann sagt das den leuten die mir das zu
senden und natürlich sagen wir fangen
jetzt fliegt hier wieder sonst hier um
ein girl gut egal ich hoffe ihr seht das
meiner fans können wenn mir so ein ding
einfach direkt auf der seite sieht man
das interface kann ich hier schon wieder
sieht man aber auch nicht die dies aber
egal leute ich würde sagen fangen wir an
mit dem ersten fake was mir nämlich
letztes aufgefallen ist ich bin übrigens
in einem sehr sehr schönen erinnern soll
ich finde sehr schöne kleine einbrachte
ich gebe euch mal den sieht fördert die
den haben wollen den staat wert und zwar
einfach zu der motorik hier in minecraft
wie sehen es ganz einfach ihr kenntnis
ich gebe lkr
daun voll ein damit aktiviert man den
regen allerdings ist es in unserer welt
so erst mal hier und damit ihr schönen
sound vom regen hört ist nicht ehrlich
ihr kennt jetzt aus unserer welt der
regen kommt aus den wolken wie ist das
ganze in minecraft wenn ich mal in die
wolken eingehen müsste man die gruppe
kommt der regen der kommt daraus ängste
der regen kommt irgendwie aus dem
weltall
also wenn man darüber mal ein bisschen
nachdenken da dies doch nicht mehr ganz
normal minecraft will immer so jakob
wir sind ein bisschen realistisch wir
fügen hinzu dass man zähne machen kann
und es gibt auch noch andere bäume und
alles ich weiß es ist immer noch ein
spiel aber guck mal ich bin nahezu
gleich schnell wieder regen ich weiß es
immer noch ein spiel aber ich finds
richtig richtig cool wenn dazu kommen
würde das wirklich bei einem gewitter
dass es nicht so an barren das nicht so
ganz plötzlich auf einmal wo spitzel auf
einer kompletten sondern dass du einfach
weil ich kann mir genau das ist schön
kreis alter jetzt mal ohne spaß an dass
sich der mann heftig episch aus jetzt
mal abgesehen kurz von den fans das ist
ja mach ich dich die leute des sieht es
das ist ja richtig es ist ja immer
wunderschön gar keine textur hier
er ist es ja mal richtig schön das ist
so eine bucht und was und wasserfall ich
hab nichts verändert jeder ist so eine
kleine schleuse ist es wunderschön kommt
egal sache ist wenn man mal so ein
bisschen nachdenkt der regen kommt aus
nix der kommt nicht aus den wolken
ich fände es ja mal so geil wenn
wirklich auf einmal gelöst warum auf
einmal du siehst du aus wird alles ein
bisschen dunkler ist es ja wenn's regnet
also wenn ihr mal nach hinten kommt und
wenn ich jetzt einfach mal ja okay ich
lasse das mal aber das wirklich so
einfach auf einmal so ganz viele wolken
so ein bisschen mehr kommen oder kommt
aus diesen wolken der regel wenn man
darüber fliegt das dann auch kein regen
mehr ist weil es ist ja auch so wenn man
in wolkenkratzer geht und man ist über
den wolken dann kann man von oben das
gewitter beobachten das kann man in
dubai machen
deswegen darf ich auf jeden fall ganz
cool wenn ich das mal zufügen würden
weil der regen kommt jetzt einfach aus
dem nichts so meine lieben freunde das
war es jetzt aber auch schon wieder mit
dieser scheiß öko kacke ich will euch
einfach noch etwas anderes zeigen was
mir von abdul
zu gesendet wurde danke abdullah der mir
das per mail an contractor gmail.com
zugesendet hat da könnt ihr die ganzen
sachen hin senden übrigens übernehme ich
keine verantwortung dafür dass ihr das
nicht schon alles kennt was ich euch
jetzt gerade zeige also dass ihr da seid
ihr schon als über minecraft ist lass es
mich in den kommentaren wissen wenn ihr
der baubescheid hashtag babo und schickt
mails schicken effekt einfach zu wenn
ihr mal die quelle schon schickt eine
andere zu naja jedenfalls ich stehe auf
einer tollen plattformen die habe ich
erst ich habe hier unseren wasserloch
gemacht wie euer zuhause
nein spaß fünf blöcke darüber ist so
eine kleine plattform jetzt fängt es an
zu regnen letzte lange ich hier gerade
vom ersten öko kacke beiseite hier
ich gehe mal in den gamer 0 männer
denken will der schneller als machen
eine fliege guck mal ich schlag hier
drauf mit links gegen rechts passiert
nächstes ökologisch ich stark auf mit
linksklick und ich kenne das wasser
nicht dass er direkt das liegt nicht
daran dass ich irgendwie sneak oder so
das ist egal wenn ich das handy kaputt
maria jetzt das wiedersehen wenn ich das
so kaputt mache sich selbst hatte nicht
das wasser durch die partikel sich das
ganze zeug auch aber wenn ich da so
mache oder so halt dann geht's halt halt
nicht das ist crazy ich weiß nicht woran
das liegt das ist irgendwie dass die
partikel eventuell irgendwie dort
einnehmen dass das wasser nicht gesehen
wird oder so diese partikel die hier
erzeugt werden
aber da müsste man endlich blöcke
darunter auch nicht sehen also das ist
ein bisschen komisch ist bei jedem block
so ich könnte mal testen ob bei denen
ernähren also das ist wie bei jedem
block so das ist bei jedem glas blog so
meine ich dass da hier irgendwie
wahrscheinlich auch noch bei anderen ihm
einfach hier würde ich glaub ich
gesprochen
auch gut tut ein bisschen weh tut
wirklich weh als katzen hier moment
jesus ist auch so mensch das ist ja
crazy dass ich sehr verrückt der ist
dann mache ich die aus dem dorf der
dritte fällt mir zugesendet wieder von
einem user per mail
ja irgendwie einen komischen hatte in
lambach 379 und zwar das sagt dieser
vergibt das hexen nicht verbrennen
können
also es war ja damals im mittelalter so
luca packt aus es war damit mittelalter
so aller hexen sollten verbrannt werden
und wenn hexen verbrennen dann sind sie
halt tod aber dann ist klar dass sie
keine hexe sind und wenn sie nicht
verbrennen
heißt es klar heißt es dass sie eine
hexe sind und dass sie dann irgendwie
geköpft werden oder so das heißt man
konnte mit alter jeden als hexe
beschuldigen jeden anzeigen und die
person war dann so oder so tot wenn die
dann wirklich gesagt wurde okay computer
auf dem scheiterhaufen
deswegen haben sie sich in minecraft
gedacht okay hexen können nicht
verbrennen ich kann jeder einfach
einsetzen ich kann die da auch rein
schubsten dass es relativ egal
die sitze drehen wird am anfang noch
ganz kurz rot aber danach also die wird
christ nicht so ich bin ein feuer
kümmert mich nicht
jetzt bleibt die der einfach drehen die
sache ist auch die kommt ja nicht wieder
raus also da können wir zehn jahre lang
warten
die kommt da nicht raus sache ist
einfach hexen verbrennen
diestel und alter freund hat eine hexe
die bleialfer viertelstunde da drin
also ich habe etwas zu essen gilt immer
noch drin oder die packt einfach nur um
das kann auch sein dass sie eigentlich
noch in dem loch ist aber irgendwie da
ist die versuchte rauszukommen
ja dies wahrscheinlich immer noch da
drin aber die brennt auch nicht mehr
crazy also die bleibt auf der höhe
das ist verrückt crazy die versinkt
einfach im boden
da sie auf jeden fall fact nummer drei
texte können nicht verbrennen
freunde seid ihr bereit für den
absoluten effekt der ganzes leben
verändern wird
also ich weiß nicht aber mir werden so
toll effect zugesendet einmal eine mail
das ist unglaublich die müsst ihr euch
auf jeden fall rein ziehen also wenn ihr
die noch nicht kennen
ich blende euch mal ein danke lp mit
niklas türen sind türen niklas ohne dich
was wird die wirtin ohne dich machen das
ist ja unglaublich weg nummer vier türen
es ist gut
jo leute wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
lass doch auf jeden fall einen daumen
hoch darin nicht leisten daumen runter
daherkommt effects weiterhin per mail an
kontrast gmail.com schreiben
entschuldigung das die vollstreckung
zuständig gesehen
entschuldigung das die folge heute ein
bisschen anders oder ein bisschen
improvisiert das hat ganz einfach den
dem grund weil es zwei uhr nachts ist
ich muss die folge noch hochladen ich
bin morgens war weg also wenn ihr die
folgezeit bin ich ganz klar weg und dann
sind alles mega stress die nächste folge
wieder besser kommt auch am dienstag
schreibt